وقتها عام 2004 كان عمري تقريبا 12 سنه
كان يوم زي اي يوم عادي طبيعي
الى ما صارت اللخبطه في في نهار هذاك
اليوم كان يوم الاربعاء
ويمكن ناس كتير ما تعرف ترى الوالد كان
مجاز في هذاك اليوم عجيب كمجاز
وراح لمبنى الوشم عشان يخلص شغله خدمه
لزميل له هناك
توجه للمبنى وحصل الانفجار في هذاك الوقت
وهذا اللي سبب لنا ربك في البيت انه
الاغلب يعرف ان الوالد مجاز ومجاز وكان
اخر مكالمه بينه وبين شقيقه عبد الرحمن
فريد العم ابو ناصر
عشان ياكد على حجزه لمكه
كان رايح مكه ياخذ عمر الوالد الوالد
وتوجه المبنى الامن العام في الوشم وحصل
الانفجار في وقتها احنا ما نعرف هل هو خرج
من المبنى ما راح هو مجاز
تلقينا الخبر على المغرب تقريبا بعد ما
طلعوا الضحايا من المبنى
وصاروا زملائه واخوانه في كل مكان يتجهون
في المستشفيات وفي كذا يتاكدون من من
وجوده
فوجدوه في احد ثلاجات المستشفيات وتعرف
عليها على المغرب صحيح
تلقينا الخبر الخبر للامانه كان
مفجع انه تفجير يعني ما كان شيء انا ما
اعرف هو تفجير سياره هو تفجير مبنى هو وش
الموضوع بالضبط
طبعا
يعني
العلاقه مع الوالد كانت يعني علاقه جدا
قويه حتى وانا صغير اللي فهمت تعبنا
الوحيد انا ابن الوحيد مع اخواتك طبعا مع
اخواتي فكانت علاقتي فيه جيده جدا ممتازه
يعني كان صديقي
فيعني في بدايه كان الموضوع
مستوعب ما ودي استوعب
يعني خبر زي ما ودك تستوعبه ودك انك تنام
وتصحى ويطلع غلط ما هو صحيح
طبعا غير علاقته بوالدته غير علاقته
باصدقائه واخوانه بزوجته اللي هي الوالده
بنات كلنا كان الخبر بالنسبه لنا كالصاعقه
لكن الحمد لله على كل حال